foreign
[Music]
I'm an assistant professor at Case
Western Reserve University and I'd like
to start by thanking the organizers for
inviting me to talk
um to you guys and tell you a story
about how we use transposon-mediated
forward genetic screens to identify cell
intrinsic resistance
path resistance cell intrinsic
resistance to emerging viral pathogens
particularly I study mostly Ebola virus
but in the process of looking for
something that would allow us to
resistible about virus we also
discovered something that allows us to
resist SARS cov2 just as the pandemic
was starting to unfold furl so I'm
really excited to share this story with
you guys today given that this is the uh
virus replication section I'm going to
tell you guys a little bit about how
available a virus gets into the cell
so Ebola virus attaches to the cell's
surface
and binds attachment factors on the cell
surface that are more or less
non-specific which then leads to
internalization and macropinocytosis of
the Bola virus particle that gets
internalized and then the virus particle
starts to get cleaved by cathepsins
which are low PH dependent proteases
that cleave back a heavily glycosylated
immunoprotective domain on the Ebola
virus glycoprotein so that's the protein
on the surface of the Ebola virion that
allows for for entry to occur this
cleavage event reveals a receptor
binding site on the the Ebola
glycoprotein that then binds to the
Ebola virus receptor in pc1 and this
leads to a conformational rearrangement
that triggers fusion and leads to the
release of the genome into the cytoplasm
and then the subsequent steps of the
virus life cycle can take place when I
was a graduate student my work was
Finding NPC one as the Ebola virus
receptor so for my postdoc when I was
thinking about starting my postdoc I was
very interested in finding ways that
cells can naturally resist this very
complicated entry pathway right so are
there ways that cells can kind of
inhibit Ebola virus entry because it's a
very coordinated dance that allows for
Ebola virus to get into cells
so the the main question I had was how
do you kind of find an unknown a good
way of finding an unknown is to use a
far a genetic screen in this case I
joined Adam Lacy Hobart and Linda
Stewart's lab to use a transposon
um mediated mutagenesis screening
technique that they had just recently
developed and this allows us to
basically put payloads into mammalian
cells that are designed to manipulate
the genome in in whatever way we see fit
in this particular case what we do is we
have piggyback so in those blue arrows
is the piggyback inverted repeats and
that flanks a pyramycin selection
cassette and then Downstream of that is
a CMV promoter that's constitutively
active along with a splice donor site so
the idea is that if it inserts
Upstream so Downstream of the promoter
but Upstream of the start codon the idea
is is that that'll lead to constitutive
expression of the gene
um
from that CMV promoter in practicality
when they did a proof of concept screen
with a Pex attacks all resistance what
they saw was also if the gene inserts in
the opposite orientation relative to the
the gene if the transposon inserts in
the opposite orientation relative to the
gene or if it's inserts into the gene
what you see is you see down regulation
of that Gene so it can both lead to
over-expression and down regulation it's
important to note here that this is
complementary to crispr screens we're
not going to completely turn off genes
but we can turn down genes and it's
completely dependent on the location and
the orientation of the insertion site
what it does to the edge said genes
um so this is a nice technique because
it allows you to turn on and off jeans
at random
and it does it anywhere there's a ttaa
site in the genome which is about one
every 256 base pairs so how do we
actually do the transposal immunogenesis
screening what we do is we start with a
cell line in our case we're starting
with u2os cells which are osteosarcoma
cells that are particularly good at
dying from Ebola virus infection and we
take those cells and we mutagenize them
using the transposon and the transposase
so we transfect in those two plasmids
and select for integrants that have our
transposon using the puromycin
resistance cassette we then take that
library of mutagenized cells and we
expose them to a selection pressure
usually a purifying selection pressure
in this case we use a fascicular
stomatitis virus that has been
pseudotyped with the glycoprotein from
Ebola virus so the glycoprotein from vsv
has been replaced with that of Ebola
virus so to the cell the virus looks
like Ebola but to us and to our immune
system the the virus mostly looks like
bsv so this makes it very safe to use in
bsl2 which is a normal lab environment
so we are able to do these experiments
not using High containment which is key
um and this is actually as an aside this
is what is one of the vaccines that's
used currently during Ebola virus
outbreak so it's very safe for us to use
so it's replication competent and it
kills off any cells it infects so we
select those resistant cells we isolate
the DNA from those resistant cells and
we amplify The transposon genome
Junction sequence that area of the
genome and then align our sequencing
results to the human genome and identify
candidates and genes in close proximity
to those insertion sites so what does
the data actually look like when we get
it out
here you can see um this is the a
representation of our our sequencing
data from a screen so the outside is
just individual chromosomes and then the
inner rings represent each individual
library that was produced in this screen
there are eight individual libraries and
what we do each of those little black
marks represents an insertion site in
the genome so what you can see clearly
is it's we see insertion sites
throughout the genome and then what we
ultimately do is look for regions of the
genome that have an increase in
frequency of insertion sites and that's
highlighted by the orange bars and then
what we do to really be able to
determine which are causative mutations
in which are Bypass or stand passenger
mutations what we do is we collapse all
of the individual libraries into one
large Library using bioinformatics and
then identify common insertion sites so
sites where insertions are increased
over a random chance so but you can see
clearly here is that there are two sites
in the genome that are
um that have
a high representation of insertion sites
and these correlate to two different
genes the first Gene is npc1 which if
you remember back about Ebola virus
entry that's the entry receptor so this
is a really nice proof of concept that
we can get virus house interactions out
of this screen and then the second
factor that we found was c2ta so when we
zoom in on those insertion sites what do
they look like right
so nc2ta you see that the insertions are
all Downstream of the endogenous
promoter but Upstream of at least one of
the two start codons in this protein
so all in the same orientation of the
genes so this suggests that it's a gain
of function Gene so that it leads to
overexpression of that Gene importantly
it has it previously been implicated in
Ebola virus infection
so what is c2ta it ends up that it's
actually the MHC class II trans
activator protein so it's a master
regulator of MHC Class 2 and other
antigen processing proteins it doesn't
directly bind to DNA itself but it
coordinates a lot of transcription
factors on that MHC Class 2 Gene Locus
and leads to the upregulation of MHC
Class 2 genes
now
data I'm not going to show you here in
the interest of time is that you know if
we disrupt this transcriptional activity
in any way either knocking down the
transcription factors or messing with
the parts of c2ta that are responsible
for this transcriptional activity we see
a complete loss of inhibition of our
resistance phenotype so so importantly
it implicated to us that transcriptional
activity is required for resistance
um and importantly you know when we
express c2d a exogenously we do indeed
recapitulate this resistance phenotype
so we're not just relying on the screen
data here but we also see it when we
recapitulated
um exogenously or express it exogenously
um so the question we had was okay if
this c2ta transcriptional activity is
required then what are the genes that
are being upregulated and when we did an
rna-seq of c2ta expressing u2os cells
which again I'll remind you are not
immune cells these are osteosarcoma
cells so we were like maybe it's
upregulating other genes who knows these
aren't immune cells when we actually
went in and looked at the genes that
were being upregulated only about 50
genes were upregulated two genes were
down regulated and almost all of the
genes were genes were involved in MHC
class II antigen processing
um importantly no known Ebola host
actors were up or down regulated
um so you know we were left with this
question is okay this is quite curious
because we're seeing a bunch of adaptive
immune molecules
um getting up regulated in these cells
that Express c2ta right
but these cells are in tissue culture
there's not an Adaptive immune response
happening so what's happening so what
this this result suggests is that one of
these proteins is leading to this
resistance at least one of these
proteins may be a combination is leading
to the resistance phenotype so when we
knock down each of these proteins
individually what we saw was that
actually it was
cd74
that was absolutely necessary for this
resistance phenotype so if we knock out
cd74 and ctta expressing cells we don't
get any resistance anymore so it was
really cd74 was accounting for this
resistance phenotype which leads me to
the next question what is cd74 well you
might know it by its uh
more uh popular name the invariant chain
or l or III so the invariant chain is
the the chain that's used to chaperone
MHC Class 2 from the ER as it's getting
produced into the um the
multi-fascicular body where the antigen
processing happens so it helps bind to
to the alpha and beta chain of MHC Class
2 and helps it to get chaperone to the
Lane into Zone lysosome where then the
cleaved antigen peptides actually get
replaced get put onto that MHC class too
and then it gets taken to the surface
and it does its adaptive immune thing
um but you know this MHC Class 2 is
really important for the transporting of
of these these molecules to this
compartment
but you know like anything in biology
and are our initial undergraduate
freshman Immunology does not nearly
describe all of the really interesting
things that this protein can do right
and there's so much more to it so it's
involved and not not only is it involved
in this chaperone function but it's also
involved in cytokine signaling as a
receptor for myth it has an internal
fragment that can be a transcriptional
regulator when it's freed by a membrane
protease which is kind of crazy it
regulates B cell maturation and the most
important for our purposes here today is
that it has a role in regulating antigen
processing
by modulating proteases that are
involved in that antigen processing
pathway
and so that's very key and remember that
when we we go on
um so how does it actually uh regulate
antigen processing so one of the things
we have to understand is that it also
has many different isoforms so biology
I'd like to say biology is complicated
and nothing is ever simple so there's
actually four different isoforms of cd74
in human cells and these isoforms vary
by either an alternative start start
site that leads to an ER retention
signal shown in purple here or an
alternative splicing event that leads to
an extra thyroglobulin domain added to
the added to cd74
and that's shown in dark blue and you
know each of these individual
isoforms has a slightly different
um you know phenotype and combination of
these two things
so we had to test each individual
isoform separately to really pinpoint
what was accounting for this resistance
phenotype and what you can see here
um is that
you know when we express p33 or any of
the other isoforms we don't see really
uh efficient inhibition of Entry or
infection from from Ebola vsd but when
we express p41 this isoform is both
necessary and sufficient for this
inhibition phenotype so p41 is
sufficient and that is on the only the
version that lacks the ER retention
signal but has that thyroclub in a
domain is important for this restriction
phenotype which really suggests that
that thyro Goblin domain and the ability
to get into the late endosome lysosome
is important for this restriction event
um
so we kind of went back and dug through
the literature to see if we could get
some Clues as to how exactly this is
actually inhibiting
um Ebola virus entry and what we saw was
that all the way back in 1999
um the the p-41 thyroclobulin domain was
actually co-crystallized with ketepsinel
as a binder to cathepsinel and here in
green is the Epson L and in pink is the
p41 thyrogoblin domain in
uh yellow there is the
um active site of cathepsinel and in the
pink space filled models are two
particular residues of p41 uh Proline
and a glycine that that help bind to the
active site of
um
cathepsino
so we use this model to design point
mutations that would that we predicted
would disrupt binding to p41
um or disrupt The Binding of p41 to
cathepsinel rather
um and what we saw was if we mutated it
to either a positively charged Arginine
residues or negatively charged aspartic
acid residues we saw an inhibition of
this resistance uh phenotype so what you
can see here is if we
mutate to Arginine or aspartic acid we
get a complete loss of that restriction
phenotype however if we mutate to a
threonine which is polar and neutral we
actually see that it doesn't really
disrupt that restriction phenotype
nearly as much
binding site abrogate inhibition really
suggesting that this this ability to
bind and inhibit contestants is
important for this resistance phenotype
so an important prediction of this model
would be that if these viruses are
unable to be processed by cathepsin L
then we would see an accumulation of
these virus particles in the late in the
zone and lysosome of cells so the
question next question we asked was can
we actually observe viruses trapped in
these endosomal compartments right if we
take cells that Express
either a p41 or C2 ta do we see a virus
trapped in these cells
and indeed this is what we see so when
we did electron microscopy to kind of
look and see what's happening on on the
the cellular level
um what we saw was you know if we have
u2os cells that Express that are control
cells we can see those in the zone with
the multifasicular bodies shown by the
arrowheads here
um and then if you have c2ta expression
cells you actually see an increase in
the number of endosomes and
multi-fascicular bodies which is
consistent with what's known about the
cell bio of the MHC Class 2 antigen
processing pathway
um and then if you add in viruses to
these cells which you see are in the
control cells up top you see maybe one
one little virion so one bullet shaped
virus
um in the endosome in the control cells
but you really don't see a lot of virus
it's very hard to find those viral
particles in these cells but in c2ta
over expressing cells which you you can
see clearly from the cutout is that
there are a ton of virus particles
accumulated well within that
multi-fascicular body so in the inside
of these endosomal compartments and then
what you also see is if we over Express
either P if we overexpress p33 we don't
see any viruses accumulate even though
we see these large vacuoles
occur we don't see virus in them but if
we express p41 which is that isoformoc
d74 that does inhibit we see virus
accumulate in those
um and this holds true when we actually
sit down and quantify so count the
number of virions per cell we see an
increase in the number of variants per
cell in p41 expressing cells and then if
we also count the number of variants per
in the zone we see an increase in the
number of virions in the endosomes in
p-41 expressing
things
um so
remember everything up to this point was
done in u2os cells which are
osteosarcoma cells they were a great
cell model but they're not really the
primary site of infection during Ebola
virus infection so the first cells to
get infected when an organism is
infected with ebola are thought to be
the macrophages and the dendritic cells
mostly because those cells are sitting
there and eating everything that they
can come across right and they also have
a lot of those endosomal dependent
Pathways so that a lot of endosomal
compartments for the entry process to
occur in so the question then was what's
the physiological relevance in these
primary cells that are the initial sites
of infection during Ebola virus entry
and you know often antigen presenting
cells like macrophages and DCs are
thought of as expressing a lot of MHC
class too right so so we wanted to
really kind of try and take a look at
primary cells to see what was going on
in this context
um of sites that might be initial sites
of infection for the virus right
um so we wanted to ask if c2ta and cd74
are also able to inhibit entry in
antigen presenting cells so what we did
was we took mice that were either
control or had c2ta or cd74 knocked out
and we took the bone marrow from those
mice we collected the bone marrow and we
differentiated it into macrophage like
cells so we added mcsf to those bone
marrow cells
um and then we either primed or did not
Prime with interferon gamma and LPS so
we either added interferon gamma nose or
we didn't add it and that just
differentiates those macrophages into a
more inflammatory like macrophage
um and so what we see is in these bone
marrow derived macrophages if you don't
differentiate with interferon gamma and
LPS you see low levels of ctta
expression and also low levels of cd74
expression but once you differentiate uh
or once you Prime with interferon gamma
and LPS into an inflammatory like say
State you see high levels of ctta
expression and high levels of cd74 and
wild type cells however once you have if
you have knockout cells that are knocked
out for c2ta you do not see that
increase in expression of cd74 upon
stimulation because ctta is not present
to actually lead to the up regulation of
cd74
so we really have to have that
stimulated state to be able to to see
cd74 or ctta expression and what we then
do is we take those cells that we've
primed and we load them with ebola
virus-like particles or vlps that
Express beta-lactamase and this is just
an enzyme that allows us to use a
fluorescence
um fluorescence fret assay that
basically allows us to sort the cells
into cells that have been entered into
and those that have not so it changes
the fluores changes the fluorescent
state of the dye ccf2 that's loaded into
these cells so they turn blue if entries
occurred or they maintain remain green
if no entries has happened and then we
take those cells and we do flu analysis
and look to see what percentage of cells
have entered or how much blam activity
has occurred
so in our c2ta cells that are
unstimulated so these are
non-inflammatory like these are just
differentiated into macrophages
um we see similar levels of infection in
both wild type and c2ta knockout cells
cells um and we see you know decent
levels of blam activity if we then
stimulate those cells we see a decrease
in the entry in the amount of Entry
that's occurring in those stimulated
cells but if we knock out C2 TA or cd74
in those cells we don't see that
decrease in infection so we see the the
in these cells when they are stimulated
with interferon gamma and LPS c2ta and
cd74 are both leading to an increase in
um or a decrease in virus entry which
once you knock out those you see an
increase in viruses century
um so this really indicated to us that
this is actually indeed that ctta and
cd74 restrict injury into
inflammatory-like macrophages so the
next question we had was what about the
other apcs so for dendritic cells what's
happening there so we differentiated
slightly using a slightly different
mixture so we use gmcsf which
differentiates into a mixture of
macrophages and dendritic cells and then
we loaded them with blam and primed them
just like we did before and then we did
a flow analysis to look and see if if
they got entered into and we sorted
based on the presence or absence of mhc2
for macrophages versus DCs and what we
saw there was in the absence of cd74 so
when cd74 is completely knocked out in
these
um in these
um macrophages and DCS we see an
increase in infection again indicating
that this is actually working in primary
cells
um and the primary sites of infection so
how is this working so just to summarize
the model thus far what we have are so
in normal cells Ebola attaches to the
surface gets internalized and then you
have those cathedapsins cleave back that
glycoprotein that reveals the receptor
binding site that then interacts with
mpc1 and that leads to the molecular
um
uh Fusion of the virus and host membrane
and releases the genome and allows for
replication to occur now in our c2ta
expressing cells
um C2 ta expression leads to the
expression of cd74
and particularly that p41 isolation
isolate of cd74 which then gets
transported to the lead into Zone
lysosome where that interacts with the
ketepsins and bicepsons
um by binding to that thyroid globulin
domain and that prevents the virus from
then interacting with those cathedpsins
and the glycopro protein processing of
of the virus is blocked and that way the
virus cannot interact with its receptor
and it no longer is able to fuse and you
get accumulation of the virus into these
late into Zone and lysosomal
compartments and you get inhibition of
subsequent viral infection
so importantly a cd74 p41 restricts
virus independent of its role in
adaptive immunity so remember all of
this is happening in tissue culture
plates this is not happening in a living
organism so there is no adaptive immune
response right so this is all innate
immunity that's that's happening and
resisting virus infection
so the next logical question we had was
okay this this we've seen this for Ebola
but does this extend to other viruses
are there other viruses that this also
inhibits or is this just like a special
Ebola thing right
um and it just so happened that you know
it was the end like I was putting the
paper together and it just so happened
that a stars like coronavirus kind of
burst into the scene
so a lot of you guys will be familiar
with this if you've been following the
literature at all so SARS coronavirus
binds to Ace two it's receptor on the
surface of the cell and then it um after
binding to ace2 there's a structural
rearrangement that happens that reveals
a protease binding site or a protease
cleavage site that cleavage then occurs
and it releases the fusion peptide that
then allows for the virus and host uh
protein membrane or virus and host
membranes to fuse and release the
genomic
um payload into the cytoplasm and first
the infection to uh finish or to
progress
um
there is also so SARS cov2 is also able
to enter via a secondary mechanism that
instead of having uh cell surface
protease like tempers 2 cleave the virus
from the cell's surface it's actually
able to get endocytosis after engagement
with the the Ace II receptor and that
leads to indus endocytosis and then
interacts with getepsinel which also
provides that that cleavage event that
is important for Fusion
so you can either have the cleavage
event happen from the cell surface or
from
um from the endosomal compartment
so a prediction of this would be that if
we have cells that um where the virus
enters solely from that endosomal
compartment so they don't have any cell
surface proteases they only have
cathepsinel that's able to mediate that
protease cleavage event
then expressing
p41 would be able to inhibit this virus
right during infection and so I just so
happen to have started at Case Western
at the time and had access to their bsl3
so I was actually able to do this with
Native SARS cov2 and what we saw when we
used Vero E6 cells which are known to
use that endosomal protease dependent
pathway
that if we expressed p41 we were able to
see a complete inhibition of uh plaque
forming units in p-41 expressing cells
and you can see that here in the bar
graph right this is just a quantitation
Quantum
quantification of the um of the plaque
assay shown on the right hand side in
the purple
um so in p41 cells you see a completely
intact monolayer whereas in control and
p33 cells you can see that the virus has
spread and killed adjacent cells
um so really p41 is inhibiting this the
virus when it enters via a low PH
um endosomal compartment dependent
protease step
um but the next logical question we had
was okay so it can inhibit
SARS cov2 if it's entering via this low
PH compartment but what happens when it
enters from the cell surface so if we
are able to express temprus 2 do we
bypass the ability of p41 to restrict
SARS cov2 virus infection and indeed
what we see so in order to do this
experiment we use 293 T cells which we
engineered to express ace2 when they
express ace2 you can see that they go
from being non-permissive to Sarge cov2
infection to having a tighter of 10 to
the fourth right
and the tcid50 is just the tissue
culture infectious dose 50 and that's
just another way to tighter the virus
um so to look for virus growth on these
cells
um so when you add p41 so if you have
ace2 expressed and p41 expressed we see
a two log reduction in the virus titers
if you have ace2 expressed and you add
tempress 2 you see a two log increase in
the virus titer compared to just ace2
expressing cells so you see an increase
in the ability of the virus to enter the
cells but if you add p41 to those cells
you do not see any inhibition of the
ability of the virus to enter those
cells so really this indicates to us the
temprus 2 entry from the cell surface
via a cell surface protease like
Temperance 2 is able to bypass the p41
Restriction of SARS cov2 so if you can
push the virus if the virus starts
entering from the cell surface then this
restriction mechanism can no longer
inhibit the virus
um so that's important for SARS cov2
right because we're only inhibiting one
of these two possible entry pathways
um so it's possible that SARS cov2
developed also this cell surface
protease cleavage dependent Pathway to
be able to kind of bypass any endosomal
inhibition right
um so hopefully I've
um convinced you guys so in summary
hopefully I've convinced you guys that
transpose on mutagenesis is a powerful
screening tool to identify host virus
interactions
um and we were able to identify a novel
host virus interaction that we didn't
previously appreciate we uncovered a
restriction mechanism that is used by a
commonly exploited viral entry pathway
so it's not just Ebola and SARS cov2
that uses use cathepsins
um for for virus entry and replication a
lot of other viruses use this pathway as
well so I think that this is a more
common or a more generalized inhibition
pathway than we might have initially
thought right
and then cd74 and C2 ta are very
well-known proteins and they have been
extensively studied but in doing the
screening process we were able to
describe a previously unknown aspect of
their biology that we never would have
kind of put the pieces together
um
with without having the screen point us
in that direction right
um and you know we were able to describe
a um largely
a innate immune mechanism for these uh
two proteins cd74 and ctta they're
originally thought to only really be
involved in adaptive immunity so this is
a really exciting kind of vignette into
how you can discover some of these
things using unbiased for genetic
screens that might surprise you
ultimately in the
um and I'd like to really take this time
remaining to thank all the people that
made this work possible this is really
fun and exciting work to do and I'd like
to thank Adam and Linda for letting me
join their lab and learn the screening
technology which is paid for uh paid for
itself in returns I also would like to
thank key Shaw who was a co-author on
this publication with me and did a lot
of the bioinformatic analysis
um and a lot of the other people at the
Benaroya Research Institute that helped
me during my post-doc and then I'd also
like to thank the people at Case Western
Reserve that have joined me and helped
me out since I moved to Case Western and
really started my independent faculty uh
career there
including the people that do the SARS
cov2 work with me in the bsl3 Michelle
Steve and Vinnie and then also the team
that's been helping me follow up on some
Ebola some other Ebola hits that I hope
to be able to talk about soon
um and Kenny matraik who's been a
consummate collaborator and has helped
me out
well thank you for taking the time to
listen to me and I'm happy to take any
questions